hello I'm Morgan with ET Canada
let's look at both okay cool that's a
very fabulous ring right dude that's my
Dad's ring Dad's ring yeah right on the
middle finger
maybe a little bit of like Teen Angst is
is represented in that ring yeah yeah
yeah just a little bit just you look
sharp hey man thanks thanks to my sister
man uh your sister dress you for real
she did because seriously uh this is my
manager name is Shana Farrell and uh
she's been with me for uh years uh she's
been managing me since I was 19 So it's
15 years and um you know since the
airport lost my bag she was proactive
and she got me this yeah they're
terrible it's bad right now it's bad and
Air Canada y'all have the worst Lounge
created in life I'm just letting you
know it's trash at least the one in LAX
is trash the one in Toronto is a bit
better but they kick you out I got
kicked out didn't expect that it's 12
o'clock we're closing where am I
supposed to go my flight hasn't taken
off okay I guess I'll go to the gate and
soak with the rest of them great
yeah man you and the rest of Canada we
are just not happy right now with
Pearson oh man hey Pearson hey that's
that's political there you go uh
I see what you're trying to do you're
trying to segue no I know I'm just
saying Air Canada everything okay we're
here it's the 40th anniversary of just
for last that's a Segway is it the 40th
really Jesus wow that's insane this is
it's a big deal but you're here host it
is a big deal I'm here hosting that's
right uh I'm here hosting in the in the
delicate of fabrics it's great like Rick
Ross you know what I mean like is that
your Tuesday no it's well I guess I mean
you know not really but you know got a
little more I got a little more sauce
than Ricky Rose sorry a little more fit
a little more fit in the in the in the
stomach area you know what I mean hey I
said a little more fit me not him he's
sorry he the one with the pop I work out
sorry I'm saying I can tell you're
working I'm sorry
she can't and she ain't got no ring on
the finger oh what's happening just
reeling it in just reeling it in here I
don't know what's happening but I'm
having a great time me too last question
before I wrap you up uh Amy Schumer's
right beside us comedy person of the
year how exciting is that oh my goodness
yo it just it just shows the hard work
and persistence can be uh can be
translated into flowers and I'm glad
that she's able to get hers you
understand what I'm saying I'm glad that
she is because she's been at this for a
minute you know and uh I've definitely
been on the road with her I think she's
funny and amazing and uh she deserves
everything so I'm glad to present that
award and she still looked like a baby
too don't she look like a baby it does
look like a bit can I tell her you said
that yeah she got a baby face she knows
Amy knows yeah
yeah that's amazing oh Pete Holmes just
showed up
oh and a nice green suit
I'm sorry okay you like your style
I'm gonna go hey it's good looks good on
you man all right good luck with tonight
so nice seeing you you're fine yeah
thank you so much
ET Canada I was like Wow BT Canada wow
this is what happens okay it's like when
I went to Romania and uh there was white
folks cooking chicken I was like I don't
think this is right this is just it was
just nothing I didn't expect a Popeyes
in Romania but when I saw that I just
said wow wow we are getting around it's
cool
[Laughter]